how did life originate on Earth you
could you could ask anybody working on
the subject and you'll get a different
answer from all of them they will be
pretty passionately held opinions and
their opinions grounded in science
um
but they're still really at this point
their opinions because there's so much
stuff to know
um that all we can ever do is get a kind
of a small slice of it and it's the
context which matters so I can give you
my answer my answer is from a
biologist's point of view that has been
missing from the equation over decades
which is well what does life do on Earth
what what why is it this way why is it
made of cells why is it made of carbon
uh why does it why is it powered by
electrical charges on membranes there's
all these interesting questions about
cells that if you then look to see well
is there an environment on Earth on the
early Earth four billion years ago it
kind of matches the requirements of
cells well there is one there's a very
obvious one it's basically created by
whenever you have a wet rocky planet you
get these hydrothermal vents which
generate hydrogen gas in bucket loads
and electrical charges on kind of
cell-like pores that can that can drive
the kind of chemistry that life does so
it seems so beautiful and so
so obvious
um that I've spent the last 10 years or
more trying to do experiments it turns
out to be difficult of course
everything's more difficult than you
ever thought it was going to be but it
looks I would say more true rather than
less true over that 10-year Peru I think
I have to take a step back every now and
then and think hang on a minute where's
this going uh I'm happy it's going in a
sensible Direction uh and I think then
you have these other
interesting dilemmas I mean I'm often
accused of being
too focused on life on Earth
to kind of
narrow-minded and inward looking you
might say I I'm thinking I'm talking
about carbon I'm talking about cells and
maybe you or plenty of people can say to
me ah yeah but life can be anything I
have no imagination and maybe they're
right but
unless we can say why life here is this
way and if those reasons are fundamental
reasons or if they're just trivial
reasons then we can't answer that
question
um so so I think they're fundamental
reasons and I think we need to worry
about them yeah there might be some deep
truth to the puzzle here on Earth that
will resonate with other puzzles
elsewhere that will
um solving this particular puzzle will
give us that deeper truth so what do
this puzzle you said vents
hydrogen wet
so chemically what is the potion here
how important is oxygen you wrote a book
about this yeah and I actually just came
straight here from a conference where I
was chairing a session on whether oxygen
matters or not in the history of Life of
course it matters but it matters most to
the origin of life to be not there
um
as I see it we have this
I mean life is made of carbon basically
primarily organic molecules with
carbon-carbon bonds and the building
block the Lego brick that we take out of
the air or take out of the oceans is
carbon dioxide and to turn carbon
dioxide into organic molecules we need
to strap on hydrogen and so we need an
and this is basically what life is doing
it's hydrogenating carbon dioxide it's
taking the hydrogen and bubbles out of
the Earth in these hydrothermal events
and it sticks it on co2 and it's kind of
really as simple as that
um and actually thermodynamically
there's the the thing that I find most
troubling is that you if you do these
experiments in the lab the molecules you
get are exactly the molecules that we
see at the heart of biochemistry in the
heart of life
is there something to be said about
the earliest origins of that little
um
potion that chemical process
what really is the spark there
there isn't
a
Spock
um there is a continuous chemical
reaction
and there is kind of a spark but it's a
continuous electrical charge which helps
drive that reaction it's a literally
Spark
uh well the charge at least but yes I
mean a spark in that sense is um we tend
to think of in terms of Frankenstein we
tend to think in terms of electricity
and one one moment you zap something and
it comes alive uh and what does that
really mean you've it's come alive and
now what's sustaining it well we are
sustained by Oxygen by this continuous
chemical reaction uh and if you put a
plastic bag on your head then you've got
a minute or something before it's all
over there's some way of being able to
leverage a source of energy well the
source of energy at the origin of life
is the reaction between carbon dioxide
and hydrogen and amazingly most of these
reactions are hexagonic which is to say
they release energy this if you have
hydrogen and CO2 and you put them
together in a falcon tube and you warm
it up to say 50 degrees centigrade and
you put in a couple of catalysts and you
shake it nothing's going to happen but
thermodynamically that is less stable
two gases hydrogen and CO2 is less
stable than cells what should happen is
you get cells coming out
so why doesn't that happen is because of
the kinetic barriers is because that's
where you need the spark
is it possible that life originated
multiple times on Earth the way you
describe it you make it sound so easy
there's a long distance to go from the
first bits of Prebiotic chemistry to say
molecular machines like ribosomes is
that the first thing that you would say
is life
like if I introduce you to the two of
you at a party you would say that's a
living thing
I would say as soon as we introduce
Gene's information into systems that are
growing anyway so I I would I would talk
about growing protocells as soon as we
in introduce even random bits of
information into into there I'm thinking
about RNA molecules for example it
doesn't have to have any information it
can be completely random sequence but if
it's introduced into a system which is
in any case growing and doubling itself
and reproducing itself then any changes
in that sequence that allow it to do so
better or worse are now selected by
perfectly normal natural selection with
the system so that's when it becomes
alive to my mind that's encompassed into
like um
an object
that keeps information and involves that
information over time or changes that
information over time in response so
it's always part of a self system from
the very beginning so is your sense that
it started only once because it's
difficult or is it possibly started in
multiple locations on Earth it's
possibly start on multiple occasions
um there's two provisos to that one of
them is
oxygen makes it impossible really for
life to start so as soon as we got
oxygen in the atmosphere then life isn't
going to keep starting over so I often
get asked by people you know why can't
we have life starting if it's so easy
why can't I start in these events now
and the answer is if you've got if you
want hydrogen to react with CO2 and
there's oxygen there hydrogen react with
oxygen instead it's just you know you're
getting explosive reaction that way it's
Rocket Fuel so it's never going to
happen but the other for the origin of
Life earlier than that all we know is
that there's a single common ancestor
for all of life there could have been
multiple Origins and they all just
disappeared
um but there's a very interesting deep
split in life between bacteria and what
are called archaea which look just the
same as bacteria
um and they're not quite as diverse but
nearly and they are very different in
their biochemistry and so any
explanation for the origin of life has
to account as well for why they're so
different and yet so similar and that
makes me think that life probably did
arise only once can you describe the
difference that's interesting there well
how they're similar how they're
different well they're different in uh
in their membranes primarily they're
different in things like DNA replication
they use completely different enzymes
and and the genes behind it for
replicating DNA so they both have
membranes both have DNA replication yes
the process of that is different they
have they both have DNA the genetic code
is identical in them both the way in
which it's uh transcribed into RNA into
the copy of of a gene and the way that
that's then translated into a protein
that's all basically the same in both
these groups so they clearly share a
common ancestor it's just that they're
different in fundamental ways as well
and if you think about well what kind of
processors could drive that Divergence
very early on
um I can think about it in terms of
membranes in terms of the electrical
charges on membranes and it's that that
makes me think that uh there's probably
there are probably many unsuccessful
attempts and only one really successful
attempt
can you explain why that Divergence
makes you think there's one answer one
common ancestor okay can you describe
that intuition I'm a little bit unclear
about why they divert like the leap from
the Divergence means there's one do you
mean like the Divergence
indicates that there was a big invention
at that time yes if it was if if you'd
got as I imagine it you have a common
ancestor living in a hydrothermal vent
let's say there are you know millions of
events and millions of potential common
ancestors living in all of those events
but only one of them makes it out first
then you could imagine that that cell is
then going to kind of take over the
world and and wipe out everything else
and so you what you would see would be a
single common ancestor for all of life
but with you know lots lots of different
vent systems all kind of vying to create
the first life forms you might say so
this thing is a cell a single cell we're
always talking about populations of
cells but yes
but the fundamental life form is a
single cell right so like or so they're
they're always together but they're
alone together yeah there's a Machinery
in each one individual component that if
left by itself would still work yes yes
yes it's the unit of selection it's a
single cell but selection operates over
generations and changes over Generations
in populations of cells so it would be
impossible to say that a cell is the
unit of selection in the sense that you
unless you have a population you can't
evolve you can't change right but there
was one Chuck Norris
it's an American reference yeah uh cell
that made it out of the vents right or
like the first one so imagine then
there's one cell gets out and it takes
over the world it gets out in the water
it's like floating around well deep in
the ocean somewhere yeah but actually
two cells got out
um and they appear to have got out from
the same vent because they both share
the same code and everything else so
unless all the you know we've got a
million different common ancestors in in
all these different vents so either they
all have the same code and two cells
spontaneously emerge from different
places or
two two different cells fundamentally
different cells came from the same place
so either way what are the constraints
that say not just one came out or not
half a million came out but two came out
that's kind of a bit strange so how did
they come out well they come out because
what you're doing inside event is you're
relying on the electrical charges down
there to power this reaction between
hydrogen and CO2 to make yourself grow
and when you leave the vent you've got
to do that yourself you've got to power
up your own membrane and so the question
is well how do you power up your own
membrane and the answer is well you need
to pump you need to pump ions to give an
electrical charge on the membrane so
what do the pumps look like well the
pumps look different in these two groups
it's as if they they both emerge from a
common ancestor as soon as you've got
that ancestor things move very quickly
and and divergently why does the DNA
replication look different well it's
joined to the membrane the membranes are
different the DNA replication is
different because it's joined into a
different kind of membrane so there's
interesting you know this this is detail
you may say but it's also fundamental
because it's about the two big Divergent
groups of life on Earth that seem to
have diverged really early on you know
I'll start from one organism
and then that organs just start
replicating the heck out of itself
with some mutation of the DNA so like
there's some there's a competition
through the process of evolution they're
not like trying to beat each other up
they're just they're just trying to live
they just replicate us yeah well you
know let's not minimize their yeah
they're just trying to chill they're
trying to relax up and there's no but
there's no sense of trying to survive
they're replicating I mean there's no
sense in which they're trying to do
anything they're just a kind of an
outgrowth of the earth you might say of
course the aliens would describe us
humans in that same way
primitive life it's just it's just ants
that are hairless
mostly hairless overgrown amps overgrown
ants